let us now move from the abstract to the
concrete recall the example that we
discussed earlier where we have two
roles of a tetrahedral die so there are
16 possible outcomes illustrated in this
diagram to continue now we need to
specify a probability law some kind of
probability assignments to keep things
simple we're going to make the
assumption that the sixteen possible
outcomes are all equally likely and each
outcome has a probability of one over
sixteen given this assumption we will
now proceed to calculate certain
probabilities let us look first and the
probability that X which stands for the
result of the first role is equal to one
the way to calculate this probability is
to identify what exactly that event is
in our picture of the sample space and
then calculate the event that X is equal
to one can happen in four different ways
that correspond to these four particular
outcomes each one of these outcomes has
a probability of 1 over 16 the
probability of this event is the sum of
the probabilities of the outcomes that
it contains so it is 4 times 1 over 16
equal to 1/4
let's now z stand for the smaller of the
two numbers that came up in our two
roles so for example if X is 2 and Y is
equal to 3 then Z is equal to 2 which is
the smaller of the two let us try to
calculate the probability that the
smaller of the two outcomes is equal to
4 now for the smaller of the two
outcomes to be equal to 4 we must have
that both x and y are equal to 4 so this
outcome here is the
way that this particular event can
happen so they're scissors only one
outcome that makes the event happen the
probability of this event is the
probability of that outcome and is equal
to 1 over 16 for another example let's
calculate the probability that the
minimum is equal to 2 what does it mean
that the minimum is equal to 2 it means
that one of the dice resulted in a 2 and
the other die resulted in a number
that's 2 or larger so we could have both
equal to 2 we could have X equal to 2
but Y larger or we could have y equal to
2 and X something larger this grain
event this green set is the set of all
outcomes for which the minimum of the
two rolls is equal to 2 there's a total
of 5 such outcomes each one of them has
probability 1 over 16 and we have
discussed that for finite sets the
probability of a finite set is the sum
of the probabilities of the elements of
that set so we have 5 elements here each
one with probability 1 over 16 and this
is the answer to this problem this
particular example that we saw here is a
special case of what is called a
discrete uniform law in a discrete
uniform law we have a sample space which
is finite and it has n elements and we
assume that these n elements are equally
likely
now since the probability of Omega the
probability of the entire sample space
is equal to 1 this means that each one
of these elements must have probability
1 over m that's the only way that the
sum of the probabilities of the
different outcomes would be equal to 1
as required by the normalization axiom
consider now some subset of the sample
space an event a that has exactly K
elements what is the probability of the
set a it's the sum of the probabilities
of its elements there are K elements and
each one of them has a probability of 1
over N and this way we can find the
probability of the set a so when we have
a discrete uniform probability law we
can find we can calculate probabilities
by simply counting the number of
elements of Omega which is and finding
the number N and counting the number of
elements of the set a that's the reason
why counting will turn out to be an
important skill and there will be a
whole lecture devoted to this particular
topic